You're not completely alone though.
Like I mentioned,
many fields have already been
addressed by machine learning.
Which means there's actually
already articles and
ideas out there that
you can build off of.
And in fact there's certain areas where
machine learning has already been
used so much that there are even classes
on how to use machine
learning in those domains.
Some of those are hosted here.
We already have classes through the
Georgia Tech program on applying machine
learning to healthcare or trading.
And so if you're interested in those
domains you're welcome to use those
materials to kind of get up to speed
on how machine learning is being
used in those areas.
On the other hand there are also
materials on other websites that can get
you up to speed on how to use machine
learning in other domains as well.
Or maybe you want to choose
one that's actually just
never been addressed before.
In which case, great,
we'd love to see what you come up with.
So, you're not completely
alone in this portion,
but we really want you to find a project
that's going to be interesting to you
that as in generate a portfolio item for
you that you'll be proud to brag about